a heartfelt speech a somber agreement a
prank involving zombies it's moments
like these that make the big bang theory
legendary even years after its final rap
these are the show's biggest moments
ranked from good to best
in the early seasons of the big bang
theory it's easy to wonder why leonard
lives with sheldon in the first place
given how difficult he can be leonard
answers this question in season three's
the staircase implementation when he
tells penny the story of how he became
sheldon's roommate when leonard started
his job as a researcher at caltech he
needed to rent an apartment nearby he
met sheldon when the latter was
subletting his apartment as his previous
roommate sebastian could no longer stand
to live with him at that time sheldon
made leonard answer a bunch of
ridiculous questions before reluctantly
allowing him to move in the two didn't
get along at first and leonard avoided
having to hang out with sheldon
preferring instead to conduct home
experiments with howard played by simon
helberg and raj played by kunal nayar
but one such experiment quickly turned
dangerous when the rocket fuel leonard
had created started malfunctioning it
was sheldon's quick thinking that
prevented the fuel from exploding in
their apartment leonard felt indebted to
sheldon and the two quickly became good
friends thereafter you're welcome
the most important way in which sheldon
retains power and his friendship with
leonard is through the elaborate
roommate agreement signed by leonard
when he first moved in the agreement
contains elaborate rules for the code of
conduct between him and sheldon as
roommates and friends naturally the
agreement is heavily skewed in sheldon's
favor but leonard's one-time girlfriend
priya played by arnie mann isn't so
easily controlled by the paradigms of
the agreement free is a lawyer and
doesn't appreciate the way sheldon
rigged the agreement to give himself
power over leonard in the agreement
dissection in season 4 priya argues
around the clauses in the contract much
to leonard's delay sheldon then
threatens to expose priya's relationship
with leonard to her disapproving parents
if the original terms of the agreement
aren't reinstated at priya's urging
leonard concedes to sheldon's demands
leaving him once again the ruler of
their little apartment kingdom
sheldon never shows much interest in
following the dictates of conventional
society his genius intellect and
anti-social nature often combine to
create a perfect storm of insufferable
behavior and it usually falls on leonard
to keep sheldon in line during his most
eccentric moments one of the biggest
instances of this occurs in season 3
with the einstein approximation in which
sheldon has been stuck on a problem at
work regarding the behavior of electrons
this leads him to try increasingly
bizarre ways to wrap his brain around
the issue while foregoing the usual
pesky human weaknesses of food and sleep
it's left to leonard to try to keep a
handle on the sleep-deprived lunatic his
roommate becomes sheldon works all night
on a whiteboard trying unsuccessfully to
solve his problem which he promptly
tosses into the street the next morning
causing a car crash sheldon also lays
out intricate patterns of marbles in the
living room in a bid to understand the
movement of electrons which causes penny
and leonard to slip and fall painfully
his crowning moment however is when
leonard is forced to follow sheldon into
a kid's ball pit that the latter swims
around in like scrooge mcduck shouting
bazinga repeatedly though leonard is
devoted to taking care of sheldon like
an older brother would this often
becomes a sore spot for leonard's
friends who think he's being taken
advantage of leonard has a major
reckoning in the season 5 episode the
friendship contraction you know what i
am sick of the roommate agreement
after a long day of sheldon being his
usual demanding self leonard invokes
clause 209 of the roommate agreement
nullifying the friendship aspect of
their relationship and reducing them to
mere roommates at first sheldon tries to
replace leonard with his other friends
but it quickly becomes apparent that no
one has the patience to deal with him
desperate to have leonard back but
loathe to admit defeat sheldon resorts
to turning off the entire building's
lights in an effort to make leonard need
his help but the ruse doesn't work
finally leonard agrees to reinstate the
friendship clause in return for an
annual leonard's day we set aside a day
to celebrate all your contributions to
my life both actual and imagined by you
one of the most accurate descriptions of
sheldon cooper is provided by leonard
when he tells penny the guy's one lab
accident away from being a super villain
sheldon's machiavellian tendencies are
on full display in the itchy brain
simulation in season seven when leonard
reveals that a forgotten dv david once
rented is seven years overdue he makes a
deal with leonard whereby he must wear
an extremely itchy sweater under his
clothes until he manages to return the
dvd so he can appreciate how
uncomfortable sheldon feels mentally
whenever he's forced to deal with
unfinished business leonard agrees to
the deal and the rest of the episode
sees him growing increasingly desperate
as he continues to wear the sweater
while trying to find a way to return the
dvd in the end it's revealed that
sheldon had paid for the dvd years ago
and was using the situation to teach
leonard a lesson about responsibility
the angry red welts and leonard's body
caused by the sweater at the end of the
episode show just how painful that
lesson is
sheldon's primary character trait
throughout most of the big bang theory
is his overwhelming narcissism he's the
most important person in his life and he
expects his friends to place him in a
similarly important position in their
lives as he amply demonstrates in season
3 with the large hadron collision when
leonard gets the opportunity to go to
switzerland to observe the large hadron
collider he's thrilled to be able to
take his girlfriend penny with him to
celebrate valentine's day when sheldon
hears about leonard's trip however he
assumes his roommate would take him
instead of penny when he discovers
that's not the case he's outraged
throughout the episode sheldon begs
pleads and schemes his way around
convincing leonard to take him
if there's one character in the big bang
theory who seems incapable of changing
it's sheldon cooper who's perennially
convinced that any problem is with
everyone else not him incredibly however
sheldon does begin to change after
meeting amy farah fowler played by mayan
bialik although he's completely
uninterested in romance at first sheldon
begins to date amy as a sort of
experiment he repeatedly insists they
aren't romantically involved but over
time sheldon begins to realize he cares
a great deal more for amy than he was
initially prepared to admit one of the
earliest and most hilarious examples of
this occurs in season 5's the pulled
groin extrapolation at first sheldon
seems completely indifferent to the fact
that leonard and amy had gone to a party
together until he misconstrued something
leonard says as a hint that they've
gotten frisky and karate chops him why'd
you do that to send a message she is not
for you
the joy of sheldon's characterization is
in watching someone with genius
intellect inhabit the body of a
hyperactive man child he has no sense of
social niceties and leonard always acts
as his reluctant caretaker all those
factors combined for a perfect storm of
hilarity in the bozeman reaction in
season three after a night out leonard
and sheldon arrive back at their
apartment to discover that the lock has
been broken and their belongings have
been ransacked although the robbers
didn't take anything of material value
sheldon becomes paranoid at the thought
of another possible break-in throughout
the episode he comes up with
increasingly elaborate anti-burglary
alarms that end up backfiring
hilariously finally sheldon is forced to
conclude that he can no longer live in a
city that's a cesspool of crime and
decides to relocate to a place where
there will be less chance of getting
murdered is he quitting his job at the
university oh no he's going to
telecommute
everybody's really excited about it
throughout the ordeal leonard repeatedly
tries to reassure sheldon that he's safe
in their apartment putting up with all
of his hysterics and ridiculous schemes
we often see leonard taking care of
sheldon and making concessions for his
off-putting behavior to the extent that
leonard almost comes across as a doormat
it's much rarer to see sheldon taking
care of leonard but the truth is despite
taking his friendship for granted most
of the time sheldon does genuinely care
for leonard the sweetest example of his
affection occurs in season six is the
decoupling fluctuation while leonard and
penny are dating it's revealed that
penny has secret doubts about their
relationship when sheldon learns of this
he becomes increasingly agitated with
the weight of the secret and its
potential impact on his friend this
tension causes sheldon to wake penny up
in the middle of the night to tell her
all the ways leonard is a great guy and
prime boyfriend material as the
thoroughly exasperated penny orders
sheldon to leave he finally drops his
usual arrogance and aloofness and
instead has a marked humility that he
reserves for only the most special of
occasions please don't hurt my friend
after many years as sheldon's roommate
leonard had gathered a vast collection
of knowledge about his friend some of
that knowledge is actively uncomfortable
like knowing sheldon's bathroom schedule
but sometimes leonard's expert knowledge
of sheldon's personal life proves
invaluable take the case of the panty
pinata polarization in season two after
a long day of having to deal with
sheldon's nonsense penny finally puts
her foot down and declares she will no
longer follow his rules this results in
penny being banished until she's willing
to apologize and take a class to improve
her attitude when penny proves
unrepentant and hostile it kickstarts an
escalating series of pranks between her
and sheldon that soon threatens to spill
over into violence that's when leonard
tells penny that he knows sheldon's
kryptonite he gives her the phone number
of sheldon's mother mary who swiftly
puts an end to the war and forces
sheldon to apologize
leonard and sheldon can often come
across as immature and ill-equipped to
handle adult life but the fact remains
that both are also top researchers in
their fields whose professional
reputations are quite distinguished
these two factors collide in an epic
manner in the cooper hofstadter
polarization in season 1. leonard and
sheldon write a research paper together
and are subsequently invited to present
it at a conference in front of their
peers sheldon doesn't want to go because
he doesn't think the crowd at the
conference has the necessary genius to
properly appreciate his work an
indignant leonard declares he'll be
going to the conference with or without
his co-author sheldon refuses to allow
leonard to present the paper alone and
also refuses to accompany him a long
petty fight ensues culminating in them
airing out their dirty laundry in front
of the audience at the conference
sheldon attempts to blow leonard's brain
apart using his mind which obviously
doesn't work the whole ordeal later gets
put up on the internet as a lasting
testament to leonard and sheldon's
bizarre relationship
one of sheldon's many quirks is his
hypochondria which is aggravated by his
genius intellect he often envisions
worst case scenarios whenever he has to
undergo any sort of medical procedure in
the season 8 episode the septum
deviation sheldon's worries transfer
over to leonard after a routine checkup
leonard learns he has a deviated septum
that prevents him from breathing
properly he decides to get a small
surgery to correct his condition but
sheldon is appalled believing that it
could lead to all sorts of complications
all through the episode sheldon remains
extremely panicky over his friend's
surgery things come to a head when the
light goes out in the middle of the
operation causing sheldon to run
screaming into the room to try to save
leonard and subsequently crash into a
glass door breaking his nose
to the rest of the world sheldon cooper
might seem like a humorless man who
takes himself way too seriously but his
closest friends know that sheldon has an
impish sense of humor and that he's more
than willing to participate in all kinds
of hijinks with the right companions one
of the most entertaining instances of
this occurs in season 5's the good guy
fluctuation while working late in his
office sheldon is beset by a series of
pranks by raj and howard sheldon manages
to see through all of them with his
trademark air of superiority only to end
up completely freaking out when leonard
sneaks up behind him in a scary mask the
incident leaves a deep impression on
sheldon and he plots his revenge against
the others all through the episode
sheldon tries to play pranks on the
others but his lack of social awareness
and the fact that the others know he's
coming make the pranks fail finally
while leonard is alone in their
apartment musing over some devastating
news sheldon pops up screaming from
beneath his spot on their couch dressed
in zombie makeup for an epically
hilarious prank sheldon never tries to
hide the fact that he considers himself
superior to his friends his dream since
childhood was always to win the nobel
prize for physics the big day finally
arrived in the series finale the
stockholm syndrome sheldon and amy win a
joint nobel for their research in super
asymmetry on the stage after receiving
his award sheldon looks over at leonard
and his friends in the audience and
realizes he's no longer the same man who
years before dreamed only of bragging
about his genius before the world
instead sheldon takes the opportunity to
thank his friends for helping him grow
as a person and as a scientist he calls
each one and asks them to stand then in
his most honest moment on the show says
i apologize if i haven't been the friend
you deserve but i want you to know
in my way
i love you all with that speech sheldon
goes from manchild to mature adult and
acknowledges the almost super-human
patients that leonard and the others had
displayed toward him over the years